this is thought to be the last photo of
helena hutchins in the white hat with
her back to us on set with alec baldwin
in the church building where he was to
shoot and kill her what happened here
remains the focus of a huge and complex
investigation and six days on for the
first time investigators and prosecutors
appeared before the cameras to confirm
that somehow there was a live round in
that gun
how did two people expect this gun
and not notice there was a live round in
it
that's that's uh what we're trying to
determine um the the
people that inspected or handled the the
firearm when it was loaded uh before it
got to mr baldwin we're interviewing
on whether anyone alec baldwin included
could face charges over what happened
does alex baldwin himself face the
potential of criminal charges all
options are on the table at this point
i'm not taking i'm not commenting on
charges whether they will be filed or
not or on whom
it is clear that even for investigators
what happened on the set at bonanza
creek ranch raises bigger questions
obviously
i think the industry has has had a
record recently of being safe i think
there was some complacency on this set
and i think there are some safety issues
that need to be addressed by the
industry
police say one focus of their
investigation is whether guns on this
set were used for target practice during
breaks in filming what they call
plinking shooting at tin cans and
whether that's how live ammunition got
where it shouldn't have been
for those experienced in handling guns
on set what happened is unthinkable
who checked that gun in the morning of
this tragedy on this particular day
who checked it
if no one checked it why wasn't it
checked
and how was that release to go back on
set to be carried out in this scene
no way this should have happened
a new police search warrant has revealed
possible gaps in the checks of firearms
that day but not how live ammunition was
there taking the life of a woman
regarded as a rising star and
potentially changing the movie-making
business for good greg milam sky news
santa fe in new mexico